hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to cards against humanity' you
guys asked for it after we did that
stupid millionaire game by Rooster Teeth
[ __ ] those guys I hate them they deserve
to die
yeah let's redo that and I may have gone
to love those guys those roosterteeth
get those I don't like it's a whole
bunch of people they're fine I've
nothing against them they sent me a
lovely gift basket that gave minutes but
what I'm trying to say is it doesn't
hold a candle to cards against humanity
which is what we got right here and in
addition to cards against men if we've
got you guys and suggestions right here
along with the Twitter handle of the
people minute right in there so welcome
Tyler welcome epon and welcome you guys
give yourself a round of applause yeah
keep going I not there we go that's good
so you guys are here which is amazing
because you guys just won a new car keep
lying we're gonna play cards against
humanity' the point of the video is we
could be as crude as we want that we can
say whatever rules I'm Markus field
jokes
welcome to this video I'm sorry I'm
sorry
that's a free market one our video
should go hi we're so sorry and we're
already sorry because we're gonna blink
cards against humanity' and we have not
seen the suggestions Amy wrote down all
the suggestions thank you so much
Katherine help shuffle these
like they're doing many cards I don't
know but a deal takes like seven right
this is the weirdest deal so who's gonna
go first who who's the last person that
committed a crime to be the cards own or
you don't want to be the judge because
makes me laugh honey I have a new role
play I want to try tonight you can be
blank and I'll be blank I'm not looking
sorry I forgot our story goes on bottom
Ethan okay
yeah so it's logical what you should do
is just place them in weird parts of the
table no I'm trying to make it work so I
don't know who did who and put Rando
oh yeah we forgot about Rando we might
need more cards and forgot about Rand oh
oh oh boy alright so honey I have a new
role play I want to try tonight you can
be Ethan's youtube career and I'll be
getting a whole effect you can be some
sort of Asian and I'll be my birth you
can be cool relatable cancer oh yeah
Ethan's YouTube career is buy at Sochi
arey Mike earth Dukakis my myth employer
and a butt blood collection is by X
broken how gross
mark has phlegm give me the sanitizer
not sponsored by German sponsored by
Germans
I wish we were sponsored by germ X I'm
holding out for that sweet germ X
sponsorship cool relatable cancer team
wins
[Applause]
every step towards blank gets me a
little bit closer to blank I could see
you stop every step towards frou bows
anal ring gives me a little bit closer
to the correct way to bleach an anus
robos anal ring is by Katie Fuchs and
the correct way to bleach an anus is by
Phil M heckler every step towards an
unforgettable Kingston tiara gets me a
little bit closer to getting caught by
the police and going to jail we step
towards the sharks with legs
it's me a little bit closer to my
boyfriend stupid penis it certainly
would be unforgettable if you got caught
by their boots yeah let's go logical on
this one an anal ring and a s that's
kind of correlated kind of correlated so
wishing that that would have been Rando
oh I'm FRA those anal ring and the
correct way to bleach an anus good call
I mean Oprah's Book of the Month is
blank for blank a story of hope I can
already tell this is gonna be great open
your eyes open your eyes but you do
I'm up until now hey you were sitting in
the background while you're working
bring the [ __ ] attention it's important
now Oh piss book-of-the-month is amazing
my mass unsheathing my massive horse
[ __ ] Oprah's Book of the Month is a team
of lawyers for three consecutive seconds
of happiness a story of Hope or Oprah's
Book of the Month is the secret formula
for ultimate satisfaction
[Laughter]
I think it's book could be achieving her
massive horse [ __ ] for a peaceful full
of horse gun in his new action comedy
Jackie Chan must fend off ninjas while
also dealing with blank now you close
your eyes sorry I saw alright it is new
action comedy Jackie Chan let's fend off
ninjas we're also dealing with eight
hates monkeys well also deadly but stuff
while also dealing with mom's new
boyfriend that sounds like I pick mom's
new boyfriend oh sorry
open up sorry you missed all of that
either one with mom's new boyfriend what
was yours bud stuff Oh
oops man this is [ __ ] [ __ ] man
this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] Ethan's peanut allergy bye Amanda
cheesy man this is [ __ ] [ __ ] back
flipping into Tyler's ass
Ethan's smoke and this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
almost giving money to like how you read
who thereby like it's a book title back
flipping into Tyler's Peter I agree you
wanna be honest about people back
flipping into your ass every night
figured you would be but when you
started laughing I expected I'm Tyler
you guys I saw this crazy movie last
night it opens up on blank and then
there's some stuff about blank and then
it ends with blank alright you're good
with you guys I saw this crazy movie
last night
it opens on Wade's face there's some
stuff about subscribing to markiplier
and then it ends with drinking
responsibly
Wade's face is by policy apply early
supplier yeah subscribing to marker
subscribing to markiplier is by it's me
it's step and drinking responsibly
okay you guys who saw this crazy movie
last night it opens
[Laughter]
[Music]
physics guys this is all this crazy
movie last night it opens on some [ __ ]
up guitar licks and then there's some
stuff about a peyote fueled Vision Quest
and then it ends with lots of I think
that is because really funny sorry no no
yeah the Japanese have developed a
smaller more efficient version of blank
okay okay
the Japanese have developed a smaller
more efficient version of PF Changs
juice buy at lovely blue boy and
moderate to severe plaque psoriasis by
authentic people in you guys think
you're funny huh because think you're
funny yeah big PF Chang thank you for
alright bros our frat house is condemned
and all the hot slam pieces are over at
gamify the time has come to commence
operation i appreciate that you're
laughing in your head alright our frat
house is condemned and all the hot slam
pieces are over at gamify time has come
to commence operation bullets the time
has come to commence operation the
hunting stare of an iraqi child
launching Ponting who I didn't speak
right the time has come to commence
operation rabies laughing
I can't explain let me enjoy this this
one's fitting my mood for these cards
this is the prime of my life I'm young
hot and fully this is the prime of my
life I'm young hot and full of dude this
is the prime of my life I'm young hot
Genghis Khan's DNA this is a prime my
life I'm young
horse you're pretty sure I'm high right
now because I'm absolutely mesmerised by
blank I'm pretty sure on the high right
the swim team all at once I'm at I'm
absolutely mesmerized by seeing my
village burned and my family slaughtered
before my eyes I'm absolutely mesmerized
by ten incredible facts about the anus I
made my bed I'm gonna go with ten
incredible facts about the ages thank
you it lurks in the night it hungers for
flesh this summer no one is safe from
blank it lurks the night hungers for
flesh this summer is no one this summer
no one is safe from Russian super
tuberculosis this summer known is safe
from Mama ear I rrx tion all this summer
no one is safe from like a million
alligators mom apply resolutely
[Laughter]
you can't handle blank you better stay
away from blank if you can't handle it's
so good I'm sorry sir but we don't allow
blank at the Country Club I'm sorry sir
but we don't allow the boner cast of the
Country Club boner cats by act Clara
underscore grooves I'm sorry sir but we
don't allow crippling social anxiety of
the Country Club I'm sorry sir but we
don't allow eating together like a
goddamn family for once at the Country
Club one more and then choose the winner
that makes it oh my compensate for my
tiny penis are you taking this half of
the deck I'm taking this half we're
picking the ultimate card oh man
pick three is slap it down there I'm
just gonna do three randos yep you do
know it's not very how am i compensating
for my tiny penis
a giant powdering man baby how am i
compensating for my tiny penis being a
super goes to make a baby oh my god been
sitting for my tiny penis
Deez Nuts oh my compensating for my tiny
penis
Denzil enzyme so how am i compensating
for my tiny penis teaching a girl how to
hand job the penis oh my god for my tiny
penis setting my balls on fire I'm
willing to Ohio
oh my compensating for my tiny figuring
out how to have sex with the dolphin I
feel I caught how am i compensating for
my tiny penis ejaculating live bees and
the bees are angry and the final card
how am i compensating for my tiny penis
the final three aren't the size of my
penis pink into a girl's butt to make a
baby
teaching her hand of the penis how am i
compensating for my tiny penis the size
of my
[Laughter]
face off all right thank you everybody
so much for watching hope you enjoyed
this let us know II thought system
comment in the comments below thanks
even thanks dad
let us know and as always we'll see you
in the next video
[Applause]